hey everybody and welcome back to roller
coaster game three
last week i had the very honorable roar
of being a special guest
on the rct3 launch live stream by
frontier developments on twitch
and um yeah it was really fun i have to
say and i'm super honored to be there
as somebody who has played this game for
so many thousands of hours and it just
means a lot to me but also i was given a
special task for that stream rather than
just
appear as a special guest and talk about
the game they wanted me to prepare
something that i could
show them and well the original plan was
just to record some simple gameplay
footage but i suggested that i just make
some
uh time lapse of the usual kind that i
do for videos and do some live
commentary there on the stream
now obviously that was just a one-time
thing so i asked them if i could
use this time lapse to make a video out
of it as well and they gave permission
for that so
that's what you're looking at right now
um so
well i got a challenge from them to work
on something specific so i didn't
totally come up with what i'm doing here
i wanted to for one do everything no
custom scenery because
well it's supposed to be a showcase of
what you can do with rollercoaster
tycoon 3 so
i figured it would be a bit of false
advertisement if it featured all kind of
modded content even though i do have to
say
i've been looking into the modded
content for roller coaster 3 and getting
all of my old mods and custom scenery to
work so maybe i'll do something with
that
but for the live stream i wanted to keep
it completely vanilla
and also i was asked to try and do
something with a spooky theme
i'm actually still not entirely sure why
but i figured it would be a fun
challenge anyway so
that's what we're going for as i
explained on the stream back then my
general inspiration for this build
is braun castle in romania which is the
real life dracula castle
which kind of sits on top of a hill in a
in a mountainous region in transylvania
it's really beautiful
highly recommend going there if you're
ever in romania or just the general
vicinity of it
um and i figured it would be a really
cool setting for a kind of spooky
coaster especially considering that i
don't have that much
experience with spooky themes in general
and especially
in rollercoaster [ __ ] 3 vanilla it's not
something i'm
really great at so i wanted to keep it
simple and
stick to things that i knew how to do
now the coaster type that i'm going for
is as you can see
a b m inverted coaster and of course
it's a
it's a it's a terrain coaster as well
because those things are just really fun
i was mostly inspired by nemesis in a
sense that the layout
follows very similar elements starting
off with a corkscrew
into a 0g roll right here and finally
ending up with a vertical loop of course
the only difference is that the
actual direction of the layout is
completely different
this one's a bit more exploratory rather
than compact
and it has a hole like a pre-lift
section
as well which has a corkscrew and a few
twists and turns and i think it's always
a nice thing to add
to a layout to have this kind of
two-step layout where
it's not just one part um but you really
have a sort of intro to it as well
and all together i think it's a layout
that also
winds itself nicely around the central
hill where the plan is to build the
castle one day
which i do think is actually the
highlight of this video as much
as i still enjoy trying to use this
coaster builder to come up with creative
layouts
because it's kind of a case of trying to
overcome the limitations
to see what you can do i think the uh
the thing that i was most interested in
building here was actually the castle on
top of the hill
also during the live stream i got some
questions about
what the deal is with my terraforming
here and why i
sort of made this this checkerboard
pattern on the other hills
and that's really just the old terrain
method of doing the checkerboard grass
pattern
to mix the textures together and make
sure you get a slightly different blend
of rocky textures
to to kind of overcome the limitations
in the in-game textures
something that's worth noting i think is
also that um
there was a way to get over these
textures by by modding it
there were old tex mod sets made by
somebody called alt spice
and later djf which were really cool
and added some custom textures to the
terrain which kind of made this whole
checkerboard pattern
a bit more redundant um but even with
the in-game textures
it just allows you to take existing
grass or sand or rock textures and make
them darker or lighter or more vibrant
um it's just a really cool way that you
can just create all of these
different mixtures of texture sets
so the station here is actually kind of
my proof of concept
for what i wanted to do for the castle
on top of the hill obviously all of the
scenery sets in the game are very
limited
so i figured that the best way to go
about
doing scenery in the base game is to try
and mix the sets
and see which pieces of different sets
go well together
i think the spooky castle walls and the
adventure
castle walls are similar enough to kind
of use them interchangeably because
sometimes there's just a certain shape
of wall
or especially these battlements that
work a bit better in the adventure set
but then i still wanted to feature all
of these stones from the spooky castle
walls as well because those do look a
bit more spooky
and are a little bit more dark and
brownish in texture
so mixing those two i think works really
well and then for the top part
i wanted to make this look like there's
some timber work on the top floors
it is something that you see in a lot of
those castles in transylvania
um and really the best option for the
timber work that i could come up with
is using the western sets to lay down
the floors and ceilings
and to add some dark trims and cornices
to the buildings
and then using the bamboo sets to create
this
sort of illusion of white thatch walls
with a wooden framework on on top of it
which honestly it's not the best way to
go about this thing but i think it's the
best that you have in the game
and especially from a distance i think
it looks convincing enough
for this type of architecture another
really positive thing i think is that
the spooky wall set is
without question the most flexible wall
set in the game it actually has all
these little pieces like
uh quarter corner roof pieces and
quarter regular
gable roof pieces and you can place them
on a quarter grit as well which is
super handy in this game if you don't
know much about this game
everything is on the grid and a grid
tile is 4
meters by 4 meters and most wall and
roof pieces conform to this as well and
i think the spooky set is a rare
um case where that's not the case and
you have these little pieces that are
only one-fourth
the size of the full grid and you can
place four different pieces
within a tile and this makes it a lot
more flexible
and means that you can build these roof
shapes that the game doesn't originally
come with
another good thing about the set i think
is that the roof is quite steep
and most of the roofs in the game are
very gentle maybe
go up two meters or one meter over the
over the four by four section and the
spooky wall set at least has 45 degree
angles on the roofs
so that's about as good as it gets in
this game and i think finally the corner
piece is actually decent to build custom
spires out of
so that's always nice i think collisions
especially are something to watch out
for with this game as well because you
can't
move different scenery pieces into one
another at least not until you've gone
into the game code and changed the
options
manually but that's something for
another day as well if i ever get into
some hardcore modding again but yeah you
always have to come up with these tricks
to try and work
some pieces together without having to
fit having to you know make the pieces
physically go into each other because
that's something you basically
can't ever do so for the castle itself
i'm using well more or less the same
pieces as i was using for the station
except of course in a different setup
here and
the trick to this castle is really just
to create a general outline of a castle
put some towers around it try and come
up with a slightly different
design for each of the towers add some
battlements to it and some
general details here and there and
that's basically it i think it's a very
standard sort of approach to building a
castle the challenge here for me at
least wasn't really to
come up with what exactly the castle
would look like but really just how to
make sure that i had enough variety and
had the right shape given the pieces in
the game which are very limited
and even though this is the spooky
castle wall set
i'm still mixing it of course with a
bunch of other scenery from the game so
trying to make everything work together
i think was one of the main challenges
here
also i think another very positive thing
about the spooky wall set is that it has
these different variations of pieces
so you also have roof pieces with
dormers on it and you can place these
dormers high on the roof or low on the
roof
there are even some roof pieces that add
some shingles that are slightly broken
or scattered to create a kind of ruined
texture
um so that's really cool honestly
there's a lot more variety in this than
i remember there being
you have to keep in mind that for my
entire roller coaster tycoon 3 stint
i was basically playing the game
completely with mods and never really
touching the in-game scenery sets
so a lot of this stuff ironically enough
is new to me even though i've probably
played this game more than 10
000 hours over the course of my life
but yeah it is what it is i guess i
think another
thing that i i sort of have my
own strong opinion on but i'm not sure
how much i agree with uh especially the
the still
active roller coaster queen three
players is that i
think there's not much of a point of
playing roller coaster
iii for the heavily modded side of
things because planet coaster exists
um if you want to build really realistic
stuff and have a lot of flexibility
i think 9 out of 10 times planet coaster
will just be the better game for that it
just looks better it's a spiritual
sequel to this game
and it's a lot more friendly on your
computer
as well and it's less prone to crash and
have huge loading
times etc it's just better in almost
every way i think there are some niche
cases though where roller coaster can 3
is still strong
i think one of these is fireworks the
game still has really cool firework
simulations and
this this awesome program where you can
create your own fireworks
which still looks great at night time i
think the lighting of the game still
looks good enough for cases like that as
well the water in the game actually is
really good for a 2004 game i think
especially
for a creative sandbox game and
they're just all these different rides
that
planet coaster doesn't have and this
game does feature i know that
i think i've talked about this either in
the last video or during the live stream
as well i forget because i
bring these kinds of things up all the
time but um
there are some cases of roller coasters
that were
built in real life only after they had
already been a part of roller coasters
tekken 3 and i think the most
interesting case
is the vertical spinning roller coaster
which is
called the dizzy something twister
roller coaster in the game
not exactly sure but it's since been
built in
schwaben park in germany there's a
roller coaster called wilde hilde which
was built in 2018
and it's the first real-life example of
this coaster type
that was already featured in this game
from 2004 so
honestly that's kind of crazy and i
think there are a lot of cases
like that there's also the uh ball
coaster or the coaster ball
in the game which is basically the real
world intamin zack spin
only the first intimins x pin ever was
built in 2005
and this game is again from 2004 so
it definitely seems like that like the
developers of this game
not only went out of their way to add a
lot of existing roller coaster and ride
types in the world but they also looked
for what kind of prototypes were
in development and weren't out yet so i
think that's super cool and i think
for that reason there are still some
coaster types that
you would have to play roller coaster
queen 3 for because you don't find them
in any other game yet
and i mean i say yes because i kind of
hope that these sorts of roller coasters
will still be added
maybe in future games in the coaster
simulation genre but i think so far
roller coaster can three is pretty
unique in that it's the only
3d game that features so many rides and
roller coasters
so i think that's still really worth
playing for that reason as well
and finally of course i think there's
just fun
in the challenge of trying to work with
what the game gives you
instead of taking all of these modded
scenery pieces that basically
sometimes already build things for you
um
at least i've been enjoying trying to
get back into these old scenery sets and
seeing what you can make out of it
and there's always a cool sense of
accomplishment from
building something intricate and
detailed from these
pretty basic pieces at least when
compared to all of the custom scenery
stuff
anyway to go back to the coaster that
i'm building here
well it's not really the coaster anymore
the castle was finished at this point
and one last thing that i wanted to add
in
was a small town at the foot of these
hills just to kind of give an idea of
the
sheer scale of the castle this was a
little bit inspired by the romanian town
of brasov which is
very close to the real-life dracula
castle and
it's just a it's just a nice romanian
town with lots of
red roof buildings um and some baroque
architecture stuff like that so very
generally inspired by that i decided to
build this town but of course it's not
quite as detailed or exactly in the same
style
although again i have to say i was
pleasantly surprised with how flexible
some of the roof pieces turned out to be
there's a set of wild west
roofs which are recolorable and just
have these nice wooden shingles that can
be used for tile roofs which i'm using
here
and in this case i made them orange
because this orange
red-ish tint is just a thing you see a
lot in romania
but it's something that i think can work
for many different themes and it's one
of those
versatile scenery sets that even though
the game doesn't feature
that much scenery and a lot of it might
not be recolorable
i think you can still do a lot with some
of the basic sets so
actually i think the western sets in
this game are my favorites because
whenever you're building anything that's
wooden or you need some recolorable
roofs or stuff for
the western set basically has all of the
main pieces that you're looking for
i think also back in the day especially
in the early days
of community creations of roller coaster
country western themes were always the
ones that were
most well executed and most realistic
looking
and i think it's a clear well example of
just the in-game scenery sets working
really well for
what you need to do with them to be fair
western is also kind of a basic theme
but i think it works alright uh another
fun thing that i think people tend to
forget a lot when they're playing this
game is that
many of the scenery pieces aren't even
in the building section
you have a lot of useful fences for
instance that you can place in
in whatever locations you want and
there's also this terrain elements
uh menu where you can add big blocks of
terrain but you can also find some gates
some various steel and wooden gates and
stuff like that
that you can place over coasters or uses
custom supports
or whatever you want and these i think
are
some of the uh the things that you don't
find as much in roller coaster country
builds but that you can do a lot with
i think back in the days that i was
getting into roller coaster country
seriously and getting into the real
community of it
so sometime around 2009 or 2010
there were always players who were
trying to make the most out of the
in-game pieces and really playing
in the vanilla or the ncs style as some
people called it or no cs
um and i think a particular example is
eloria
aka stephen who's made a lot of indoor
swimming pools and theme parks and
things like that
and i remember watching a lot of their
videos that was
honestly my childhood i think there's
also moonkin for the win
of course who made the box series which
i recently did a coaster inspired by in
planet coaster
but the basic box was also done without
any custom scenery and i think
a lot of these videos show that even
though there was a super alive modding
community for roller coaster country
there's always been this push by many
people
to also keep it vanilla and see what you
can do with the base game
i also got a comment from somebody on my
last video about piece of prestige who
is an
old roller coaster country player who
always focused on doing stuff without
custom scenery
and they were wondering if i knew his
youtube channel which is kind of funny
because i actually
still talk to him on a somewhat regular
basis um but yeah
highly recommend his videos too if
you're if you're in 2020 and you want to
live that 2010 life and go back into
roller coaster [ __ ] 3 builds
i recommend all of this stuff just
alloria moonkin for the win piece of
prestige these are just some examples
but i think there's a lot out there um
and i think even for planet coaster
players
you can find a lot of inspiration in
rollercoaster tycoon 3 builds
that community was very small but it was
super passionate about theme parks and
i think even more than the planet
coaster community it was very
focused on constructive criticism and
trying to raise everybody up
in a sense that people are always
helping each other get better at the
game
and discover tricks and tips and things
like this and i think
inevitably the planet coaster community
has lost some of that drive
in a sense that it's just a bigger group
of people and it's a bit more casual
and a bit more focused on fun because
not gonna lie the roller coaster country
community was a bit dramatic at times
and
um super passionate about this topic
but still it was really cool to to see
how
people just just got this communal
spirit from this game
and focused so much on trying to make
everybody better at it and i think
as a result of that there are some
rollercoaster 3 builds which
nowadays can even be great inspiration
for planet coaster
they might not look that great
graphically
but there are some really some really
great thought behind it in all of the
details
and composition and layouts for theme
parks and such
i can't really name anything off the top
of my head that i think
is is a great straight example for
planet coaster builds but i know that
personally i've always had a folder of
builds by leonidas who you can find
still on new elements and also has an
old photobucket account
whereas lots of really great roller
coaster queen 3 builds
and they're also just great youtube
videos there's
arm puzzle which is one of my favorite
coasters ever built in the game
um you can find on mike sheets channel
who's still active in planet coast and
planet zoo some really great
coasters in rct3 as well and of course
i don't want to plug myself too much but
there's my old youtube channel called
silverad archive where i have a lot of
my old rollercoaster
3 stuff saved as well as of course some
videos on this channel
so i think there's a lot of stuff to go
back for and even if you already own
planet coaster
or if you don't own planet coaster and
you're still sticking with roller
coaster country
there's been so much amazing content in
this game that honestly
i can just talk about for hours and just
let my stream of consciousness go on
about
unfortunately that's something i can't
really do in this video so
i'm just gonna leave it here and share
with you guys a quick cinematic clip and
pov
of this coaster hope you guys enjoyed
this little
off the cuff roller coaster 3 video
again
um i'm sorry if it's not quite as
in-depth or
thought out as my videos usually are but
i figured after preparing all of this
for the launch live stream i didn't want
to just
leave it in the void and do nothing with
it um so here you guys go
hope you enjoyed and i'll see you on the
next one
[Music]
you
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]